I'm gonna be a spaceship engineer.
Nice!
It's my passion to be singing on a stage.
I'll probably buy Jupiter.
I'm going to be a bubble master.
I don't understand it when adults are so busy on their phone.
All they do is just...
"I have to get this done, stop talking to me."
Stressed out, tired, they're sad.
I don't understand why adults get so stressed out.
Yeah!
Time goes fast.
It certainly does.
Oh, trust me on that one.
How did I ever get to be this age?
It happens overnight.
It's like, you go to sleep and you're 25 and you wake up and you're 70.
When I was thinking about being 55 years old...
...and thinking I was going to be old and decrepit...
...and then, the next thing I knew, I was 60.